- Elizabeth Grigsby, many of you know Liz.
Liz is a client, and advocate
for the Golden Gate Regional Center.
Liz has spoken at the
conference many times
and she is going to introduce
the Shriver Award winner,
Amy Restling, who is
gonna accept the award
on behalf of the ARCA organization,
which is the California
Association of Regional Centers,
I think I said that right.
Yes, okay, good.
Each year we award an
organization or a group
who's made a considerable
contribution to improving
the health and the lives of people
with developmental
disabilities in California
and there's no better
organization than ARCA
to actually receive the award this year
and I think we started
the conference hearing
about the history of the Lanterman Act
and the history of the Regional Centers
and it's really our
pleasure to acknowledge
their incredible work
over the last 50 years,
has it been?
Let's just give a little
round of applause for--
(applause)
Want me to hold this for you?
Okay.
I do not.
- It'll be just a second.
Here we are.
- Sorry for that.
I would to talk about
a lady, Amy Restling.
Amy Restling is currently the
interim executive director
of the association of Regional
Centers Agency's ARCA.
She joined ARCA in 2012
and has focused on services
for children at risk of
developmental disabilities,
assessing health and insurance
funding for autism services
and the service system.
Prior to that, she worked
for ARCA California Regional Center
coordinating the movement of individuals
with developmental
disabilities, institutional
to community.
Yes!
And she also worked for
Central Valley Regional Center
overseeing services,
coordinating in rural Merced
and Mariposa counties.
Amy also worked for Disability California
advocating for individuals
with developmental disabilities
in the central valley.
Amy earned both her bachelor's
degree in social work
and master's of public administration
from California State
University in Fresno.
So it's my pleasure to
introduce Amy Restling.
(applause)
- Thank you Liz.
- Thank you all so much for being here
and thank you, Liz, for
that great introduction.
I really appreciate it and
I first just wanna welcome
or just wanna say thank
you again, for being here
and on behalf of the Association
of Regional Center Agencies
and really on behalf of
all the Regional Centers
in California.
Thank you for the award.
Today, just wanted to talk a little bit
about our service system
and what makes us unique
in California and where
we think we're headed.
And today we'll talk
briefly about the structure
and history of California's
Developmental Services System,
'cause we never get tired
of talking about ourselves.
(audience laughs)
We'll talk about how the feds look at us
and we'll talk about
factors that are gonna shape
our future or those that we think will.
And then we will try to reserve
a few minutes at the end
for question and answer.
What makes California's system unique?
California's system is
unique because it began
with families.
It began with families
saying, "I want an alternative
"that's different from
institutional care."
In the 1960s, California
supported over 13,000 individuals
with developmental
disabilities in state-run
developmental centers and
there was a waiting list
to get in.
Families came to the legislature and said,
"there has to be a better way."
Through cooperation between
both republicans and democrats,
the service system was developed.
To this day, it remains widely supported
in a bi-partisan way.
At that time, federal
funding was only available
for institutional care, but
California made a commitment
to serve people with
developmental disabilities
in community settings, even without that.
Now every state in the country has
a developmental services
system that is community based,
but ours remains one of
the few entitlement states.
Other states will tell you
they're an entitlement.
We like to disagree with them.
And the other thing that
makes our system really unique
is it's not government run.
It is designed to be responsive
to the individual needs
of individual communities
because the state,
when they were putting
the system together,
came to the realization that
the needs of individuals
and families in this
area are very different
than those of individuals
and families in Fresno.
The challenges and the gaps in services
are all very different.
Each regional center has an
independent board of directors
and 50% of that board
must be either individuals
with developmental disabilities
or their family members
to ensure that the
system remains responsive
to those who rely on it.
Really, the regional center is here
for three real basic purposes.
To help infants and toddlers to reach
their developmental potential.
To help children to stay at
home with their families,
because remember, this was at a time
when if you had a child with
a developmental disability,
you could either put
them on that waiting list
for the developmental center,
or you could take them home
and take care of them
entirely on your own,
and too many families were
making the first choice
out of necessity.
And then the third goal of the
system is to support adults
to live as independently as possible.
Regional centers don't do
the day-to-day hands-on work
with individuals, but they fulfill a lot
of important functions.
They provide intake and
eligibility to ensure
that people who qualify for
services are brought in.
They provide lifelong service planning.
Talking about what is it that
you need and how can we help
you get it?
They provide clinical support,
oftentimes acting as a hub
of excellence for medical
information in their communities.
Regional centers were designed
to fill in gaps in services.
They aren't here to take
the place of other services,
but they're here to help
you access other services
in your community through
things such as MediCal,
in-home supportive
services, special education,
and the like.
And lastly, regional centers
fulfill a critical function
in meeting federal expectations
because while the system
was started without
federal dollars, today,
it relies on a tremendous
amount of federal funding.
Speaking of which, you'll
see that, I wish the colors
came out a little better, but that's okay.
The first 40% of the funding in our system
is federal dollars and so
it's essential that we meet
those expectations of
the federal government
and keep those dollars coming.
At this time, the Regional
Center System has a total budget
of 6.1 billion dollars or so,
with about 2.5 billion of that
coming from federal reimbursement.
Because the money, we care a lot
about what the federal
government thinks, right?
The way our service system is structured,
and please excuse the crude flowchart.
It was my first time making
one and I was super proud
of it, so I stuck it on the slide.
(audience laughs)
But basically, service providers report
to the regional center about the progress
of the individual, as well
as for billing purposes.
The regional centers bill
the Department of Developmental Services.
The Department of
Developmental Services bills
the federal government, money comes out
of the federal government,
and it all goes back up
the stream the other direction.
The reason that it all goes
through, or the vast majority
of it goes through the
Department of Health Care Service
is they are what we call in California,
what we call our single
state entity for Medicaid.
Basically the federal
government doesn't wanna talk
to every department in
this state or in any state,
for that matter, so most of
this funding is Medicaid funding
and it has to flow through
the Department of Health Care Services.
The federal government
pushes a lot of initiatives
on states, and the good
news is that in California,
we've always had a very
progressive system.
We've always wanted to
see people participating
in their communities.
We've always wanted to see
people living independent lives
and so some of the trends
that are being pushed
at the federal government,
at the federal level,
are much tougher for
other states than they are
for California at this time.
Some pose a challenge,
frankly, because of the scale
of our system.
We serve 300,000 individuals
with developmental disabilities
in the state of California.
Other states, for example,
the state of Tennessee,
serves about 8,000.
You'll begin to see why
that's a challenge for us.
First and foremost, the federal government
wants to see person-centered planning.
They want to see that the
person and their needs
and their individual wants
and desires are central
to the determination of what
services they will receive.
I heard one speaker one time refer to this
as finding that balance
between what someone needs
and what someone wants.
What the person requires
and what makes their life
worth living.
And that's really how we look at it.
It is possible to meet someone's
health and safety needs
without really giving them
the life that they desire.
And that's really the balance
that we strive to achieve
here in California.
We started doing person-centered
planning in one form
in 1992 in this state and other
states are just now starting
down this path.
Conflict free case management.
In California, as I
mentioned, regional centers
don't provide that
day-to-day direct support.
In some other states,
the agencies that provide
the case management function
are also service providers
and you could see the potential
for conflicts of interest
there.
The federal government
wants to see higher levels
of community integration.
They wanna see people
out in their communities
and they wanna see people
part of their communities.
We are continuously growing
and changing in this way.
Having less settings that
are set aside just for people
with disabilities, and
finding more creative ways
to support people in natural communities,
which we believe is good,
not only for the individual,
but for the community as well.
There's also an emphasis on greater levels
of community employment.
As we know, employment
isn't just about a paycheck.
It's about a sense of
belonging, it's about finding
a community, it's about
creating a space for yourself
in that community, and so the
emphasis at the federal level
and at the state level as
well, is on helping people
to find their place in this world.
Measuring outcomes.
We can really easily
measure what we provide,
but we're working hard to begin to measure
the ultimate impact on someone's life.
We don't just wanna provide services.
We wanna provide services that
make people's lives better
and that make them
fulfilled, and that help them
to achieve their goals.
One method for measuring
progress in this way
is the National Core Indicators Project,
which soon, all 50 states
will participate in
and it allows us to compare
outcomes from California
to other states and also,
across regional centers as well.
For instance, here is a chart from
the National Core Indicators.
This is the proportion of
people who describe themselves
as having poor health and
this is the national chart,
I believe.
Yes, it says all states.
So you can see the percentages there.
And then you can see in
California that we have
a greater number of people
who report themselves
being in good health and less
people reporting themselves
being in poor health.
And those are the kinds
of outcomes we wanna see.
Those show us that services
aren't just being provided
for their own sake, but
they're making a difference.
As we look ahead, the state
is asking lots of questions
of the Service System.
We're not a stagnant system.
We continue to grow.
Next year it's expected that we'll grow
by 14,000 individuals, which
is about a 3.6% growth rate,
which far exceeds the
growth of the population
in the state.
Over time, our demographics have shifted.
We're seeing far more
individuals with autism,
we're seeing larger numbers of people
who are outliving their caregivers
and we're having to figure out what to do
with an older geriatric population.
The system is also asking
what services and supports
will help the families to stay together.
Here in California, 78% of individuals
with developmental
disabilities live at home
with their families and that is essential
to the way our system works.
Providing critical family support services
to help families to stay together
when that's the desired outcome.
We're also beginning to look
at and continuing to look at,
what are the opportunities
for what to do next?
Where can we enhance the system?
Finally, how can funding
be adjusted to ensure
that it remains sustainable?
We have an entitlement
system here in California.
Individuals are entitled
to services and supports,
but every year, the system must continue
to seek out funding through
the legislative process.
Concerns on the horizon.
Now we're glancing across
the country to Washington.
I know people in this
room are really concerned
about all the things that
they're hearing out of Washington
and so are we.
The four things that
could have a major impact
on our service system are,
of course, any changes
to the Affordable Care Act.
Some of our funding, as
I mentioned, much of it
is Medicaid funding, so we serve
the Medicaid expansion population.
We also receive a few hundred
million dollars a year
through an expansion of
federal funding specifically
for our service system.
That was part of the Affordable Care Act.
We're continuing to watch these things.
We also know that because
our system fills in gaps
in services, that when new gaps open up,
that poses a problem.
If people begin to lose
health care or if they lose
access to other services, that's a problem
for the people that we support.
We're also very concerned about
Medicaid funding structures.
You hear, in Washington, talk
of Medicaid block granting
and this, at least the
third time that idea's
been put forward, but
we're still concerned
for a number of reasons.
First, Medicaid block
granting is really hard
on high growth states.
We're a high growth state.
Additionally, we're unclear
what that will look like
because Medicaid funds
don't just go to fund
doctor's appointments
and physical therapy.
They also go to fund a
number of social services
through the Regional Center, through IHSS,
through all kinds of things.
That's a very real concern for the system.
Any changes to Medicare, also
a concern for our system.
We have a number of
people, particularly those
who have the greatest
levels of medical fragility
who are Medi-Medi.
So changes to the
Medicare funding structure
could adversely impact them.
There's also talk of changes
to special education.
Again, we look at the
comprehensive whole person
and we have to think about
what are the challenges
that not only our system will face,
but that these individuals
that we support will face
and their families will face.
Those are things that
we continue to monitor
and continue to try to
educate our lawmakers about.
As if that's not
depressing enough (laughs),
and sadly those are things
that keep me up at three AM
thinking about Medicaid block granting.
Hopefully you all, if
you're up at that hour
have something else to worry about.
A final thought.
Our system turned 50 years old last year
and there's a great video
called We're Here To Speak For Justice.
If you haven't seen it,
please take the time out
to do it.
It's from those inspirational
families who founded
our system and who gave us the
backbone of what we do today.
One of them said, "we were
clearing away new paths
"to get the work done,
to get what we needed.
"They didn't exist, so
we had to work on it
"so that they did exist."
Today, we consider ourselves
continuing to chart
new paths where they
didn't exist yesterday.
Any questions?
(audience applause)